Nikesh eat in countries to study
fertility rate and life expectancy she
noticed a strong negative linear
relationship between those variables in
the sample data here is computer output
from a least-squares regression analysis
for using fertility rate to predict life
expectancy use this model to predict the
life expectancy of a country whose
fertility rate is two babies per woman
and you can round your answer to the
nearest whole number of years so pause
this number and see if you can do it you
might need to use a calculator alright
now let's do this together
so in general this computer output is
actually giving us a lot of data more
than we need actually to do this
prediction but it's giving us the data
we need to to know the equation for a
regression line so the general form of a
regression line a linear regression line
would be our estimate and that little
hat means we're estimating our Y value
would be e would be equal to our y
intercept plus our slope times our x
value now in this situation we're using
fertility to predict life expectancy or
let me circle all of life to expectancy
so the thing that we're trying to
predict that is why life expectancy and
fertility is the thing that we're using
to predict that so that is going to be
our X right over there now what are a
and B well our computer output gives us
that it's these numbers right over here
our constant coefficient right over here
this is a and our slope is going to be
negative five point nine seven you could
view it as the coefficient on fertility
remember this right over here is
fertility you could even write rewrite
this as our estimated life expectancy
estimated life expectancy I could put a
little hat on it too so this is
estimated life expectancy is going to be
equal to eighty nine point seven zero
minus five point nine seven times
fertility times fertility rate I'll just
call Seifert and period right over there
and notice this is the coefficient on
fertility and then this is the constant
coefficient you could view that right
over there and now we can use this to
estimate the life expectancy
of a country whose fertility rate is two
babies per woman for fertility you just
put a 2 here and then you get your
estimated life expectancy so what's that
going to be we can get out a calculator
so we can say five point nine seven
times two is equal to that and then we
want to subtract that from so I'll put
it with negative there and add that to
eighty nine point seven is equal to and
we want to round to the nearest whole
number of years so that's approximately
78 years so this is approximately 78
years and we're done and just to be
clear what even happened here is that
Nikesh she did a regression on the
x-axis is fertility fertility on the
y-axis is let's call it L period that's
our y-axis took 10 data points one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
put a regression line on tried to fit it
try to fit a regression line you saw a
negative linear relationship and then
using this regression line to estimate
hey if fertility is let's say this is
two right over here what is the
estimated life expectancy and we just
saw that that would be roughly 78 years